you are an animal lover and i'm told
that you love snakes which i find hard
to believe because i love animals but i
don't like you love snakes yeah but are
they an animal
yes they're not a vegetable yeah i'm in
my school uniform
a reptile a reptile yes but i don't i i
i like all kinds of animals i mean i
really like i even like bugs but but
snakes i find
a little bit creepy you love them yes i
well i i have been known to wrap myself
in a snake or two what yeah you you wrap
them just buy a belt
wait you wrap your body in snakes yeah
incredible yay is it just for fun
i like it yeah yeah i do no i really i i
don't know it's just something i really
like snakes i mean i'm
it's but it's got to be a snake that
you've hung around with you're not
trekking through the wilderness and you
see a snake and you grab it and suddenly
it's
a scarf
no but say i've been i've i've certainly
had um
um
anyway
no
now i'm really fascinated
you've had some weird encounters with
snakes we've done that i'm open to
snakes you're open to snakes
there are snakes watching right now
wait they don't have fingers what am i
doing
no i lie
[Laughter]
open to snakes anyone out there
have you ever owned snakes
um
no but i've had i
had a party actually once where i was
going to well i've had snakes at parties
before but i had a halloween party this
this year and we had to cancel the snake
charmer because the kids would be too
scared
wait you had a party for kids and you
booked snakes for the party
what kind of monster are you
i've also had a party where i've had
lots of different wild animals and yeah
i love animals but that sounds fun
actually you actually come to one of my
parties yes i would love to come to one
of your parties she's laughing because
she's saying that's not going down my
wild friend
i would love that actually do you think
any of that comes from being from
australia just loving it
actually yeah it's kind of well we go up
with things like spiders in the pool
what spider's in the pool yes we have a
spider called a funnel web
which can exist in a bubble we really
are in school now yeah um
it can exist in a bubble yes in the pool
wow um and you have to look in the pool
uh before you swim to make sure that i
mean this isn't frequent but you know
you have to check i know to check the
pool is it a deadly snake
no it's a spider oh spider spider i'm
sorry that's what i meant i meant spider
i was listening i swear to god i was a
little
you're not gonna pass your exam no i'm
not
is he staring at the teacher uh
uh no but i'm just is it a deadly uh
spider yeah oh yeah the funnel web is
see that's what this sounds like that's
20 minutes
20 minutes
well above to get to a i mean i hope i'm
speaking accurately but i think i go to
you for all my medical advice
you're gonna get sued by
australia
spiders
be like she's wrong but um yeah no well
anyway but yeah that's sort of what else
do you want to know about i'm just
curious about like in australia that's
just the thing that you've always sort
of the we know yes the myth that you
know that there are kangaroos with
knives that you know there's things
that there's lots of danger there's
bears with guns you know just craziness
everywhere that's what you want to hear
about australia there's a blue ringed
octopus what's that that's an octopus
that will
kill you well maybe it sounds like
everything in australia will kill you
what kind of rabbit's that the calling
that kills you you know